good morning gamers okay okay okay okay
Mendy
I have it finally after three episodes
please please just sell me your mending
I've been trapped yes
it's locked then thank you
so I had it last time no one cares Felix
it's just that I had it and then he
changed it now I have it thank you
all right gamers today we have a lot of
stuff to do first off I want to show
while I was desperately trying to find
the books we have two new friends two
new kitty cats so I just been keeping an
eye on them
Lulla bleep that I don't know what to
name the other one so you guys give me
names and all all top comment besides we
have you locked in place this guy is not
gonna change this profession because we
traded with him that's how this works we
have the freaking chamber which is not
working at all so we're gonna have to
redo it there's gonna be a couple
changes around here just for a brief
moment we're just gonna cover up this
window so no one else can see what's
happening just do it
just as minor detail no one needs to see
what happens in that's so weird everyone
just disappeared all the villagers well
no one could see it apparently villagers
gossip so if you hurt someone they'll
give you worse prices so that's lucky
that they just left and I didn't have to
hurt them why am I always full of stuff
every time I play it's like I don't know
what at okay so these two you lucky see
they already like each other this is
this is perfect
they're gonna be our new breeders you
guys are gonna be like Adam and Eve yes
see see now he's a normal villager I'm
taking no chances with you - you will
freak whether you like each other or not
this is gonna happen this is happening I
mean oh yeah I built that piggy statute
it does it we're doing it more important
things okay so here we are the idea is
that they're gonna stay here
I don't know if this works no one's
tested out freaking method then we're
gonna put this here this here and this
here and I'm gonna have to somehow get
them down there get in hole Oh perfect
no how am I gonna get both for them in
there come on come on oh closed this is
so romantic you will be together forever
you will populate an entire city think
about the consequence I will pay you I
won't pay you but I could you kick come
on you're why can't you stay in a hole I
don't ask for a lie yes yes ha ha ha
okay gamers they are stuck in the hole
of friction yeah we have Brad making
sure they actually do it you know for
moral support
now what we're gonna do is wooden plays
a dispenser that will make food fold
downs because they need food to frick
and I don't know how exactly look I
think they're already getting a Sorry
Sorry Sorry Sorry Sorry
I guess I'll wire it to go here so three
up and so we will place dispenser
looking down as such oh no I'm stuck in
friction BRR No
ah gotta push them down the Frick hole
pushing they lit Frick Hall I push my
boys down the Frick hole get down in the
hole get down Oh get down in the
get-down hole oh yeah get in the Frick
hole
absolutely stunning hey but it will I
know it's kind of silly to spend the
whole kiss time of this it will be worth
it trust me alright let's just put some
rotten flesh Annie works excellent let's
get all our favorite our finest potatoes
put them in the dispenser as search I
think I would prefer if he like goes
well oh sorry that's probably not good
right there we go ah I don't need to go
near you lose yes that's how I like it
I just want it to be like a total creep
in the ground now we can witness the
lovemaking sending the potatoes I
thought it would continuously send in
potatoes this is super annoying maybe I
need some sort of repeater okay so I
need to figure out a way to make it
constant pulse it's going good right he
agrees okay so now signal is constantly
pulsing
this doesn't make any sense though like
how do I stop it oh I see if I sit right
maybe if I had a button then right no
that doesn't work it needs to be a
higher tic and just stop it
just click it again doesn't work at all
if I have a lever though I can just
brink and activate it to stop it this is
so dumb that it might just work
okay so I think I figured it out
because now we have a constant pulse
going and then we turn it on which is
technically off and then it's just a
constant flow which will make it stop
big brain let's try it out okay I think
I I think I did it man your redstone
engineers better watch out let's try it
out bread man
I heard it's working yeah when you
figure that redstone it feels so good
let the fricking begin that's right
enjoy those potatoes they're like what
is happening wise potato run from
ceiling don't worry don't worry he can't
see us for me they can't see us from
here
Macbeth back now we play the waiting
game let me actually let me clean it up
there I guess we have to just wait for
them to very well we shall wait in the
meantime I think it's dang time that I
start utilizing this mending thing maybe
I over evaluate it what the so we have
this badass Triton right that we really
want it we want to keep this but it will
break eventually I have an arrow in my
skull or our diamond sword yeah let's do
it on our diamond sword this would
probably cost a lot but it will
definitely be worth it so we put mending
on it and now hey something actually
spawned for the first time when we get
XP maybe try it on some people who-who I
think we can spare a couple you see that
you saw that on the sword
it went up sorry people for oh my god
they are already cooked the pork chop
because they burn oh that's so sad
why am i laughing ah so the experience I
get from cheap chop chipping goes not to
me goes to the sword so sword lasts
forever now I won't level up though so
that's that's a problem I just keep
hearing them flipping and plopping but
no freaking and friction you know what I
mean I know I'm not supposed to be in
here but come on guys you gotta do me as
but I come back there better be a baby
that's all I'm saying I think it's safe
to say as disappointing as is this the
frickin machine doesn't work and I can't
figure out why maybe it has something to
do with the fact that their restraint
down there you know wow how many did
they spit out 64 guess you guys don't
like potatoes huh if you guys are
disappointed just imagine how I feel
alright maybe we should just go with a
more natural approach and just hope that
they do something
it's like you build someone a freak
chamber you think that I'd least be
grateful
are you comfortable sleeping God take
another bed Oh
oh my god it's happening oh my god they
love each other finally don't let me
disturb you I'm not even here
bad bad bad bad
thank you
I also made a what is it paper farm
because I now I actually need it to
trade with love librarian since that how
do you even get in what is baby
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
where did his spawn from I'm so sorry
for your loss have some potatoes oh my
gosh get out you suck
seriously they love it they're like it's
working when they have another baby yes
keep eating it loves it look how cute he
is
finally the freaking chamber is working
they're like what this happened why
potato rain I don't know but that
suddenly I feel like having bad back
that's right that's right
raining it's raining please make the
thunder rain please please I beg you
cancel them what the shoe I think
oh my god what does sheep answered the
prayer hey get the Trident get the
dreaded I'm so excited for this
all right piggies go it doesn't along
[Music]
just throw it at him give me back I can
make the freaking Thunder baby but the
power of Zeus this is so badass dude
we're gonna destroy not to me a video
I'm innocent
Oh God sorry sorry great my god oh my
god
they'll forget about the fact that I hit
them right don't forget eventually
nice chill I didn't mean to I didn't
mean to hit you more oh my oh this is so
cool
more I was trying to help them from the
fire by the way hope you understand more
guys please oh the fence breakdown
oh-oh-oh
I think I did an embassy I think I did
at Big Ups in here by our main my army
my peepee poopers don't I have not
betrayed you please you must understand
I hit you on accident okay maybe if I go
to sleep they will calm down it's like I
don't oh my god they're attacking me oh
my god oh this is the end this is the
end
escaped to the mines oh gosh
so then I'm going on holiday just make
sure you what have I done oh god what
have I done
you guys don't mind right every cool
cool so you guys we're cool we're cool
we're all cool here will you attack me
thank me guys this is my house I live
here
hey gay okay how to make pigs stop
attacking you I forgot to add Minecraft
in Minecraft I have to escape 40 block
radius that was badass though alright
we're cooling that right yeah I don't
think we're cool you want to kill me
don't you oh my gosh we're cool ha
they've got worst memory than I had wait
a minute wait a minute
did the old despawn because I left the
area you've made one baby we'll make
more can I just change the weather can I
do that
I feel like doesn't really benefit me I
just kind of want to see if there's
works at this point and I don't want to
wait so I promise I pray this is a
PewDiePie promise I will not never not
on my spare time not another thing use
it okay okay so technically I said I was
gonna use creative mode and changing the
weather isn't creative mode so facts and
logics you know what I mean I took all
these steps for days I I just want to do
I don't want to do it
it's got to make sure I don't hit any
one of them yes okay it's working
whoa it's so badass seriously the
coolest thing more more people village
yes hahaha
God if I mess up now whoa
another Thunder hit the randomly why
army by arming tonight we kill finally
one of the first bosses
tonight we dine in Hell I just realized
I haven't prepared for this fight
whatsoever
she probably closes up then you should
probably go inside oh god it's so creepy
so I think it explodes right away here
we go go
why does he targeting
I can't shoot him what was that whoa
[Music]
attack something then Oh God
get him zombie
always targeting me
[Music]
got damaged distraught
[Music]
faster
come on
have help
where do you see I can't see Oh God
thanks for nothing stumpy pigmen
[Music]
my dog is destroying everything
[Music]
I'm just gonna make sure I don't hit the
pigs cuz then I'm okay this is stressful
and you'd help how is there more of them
still he's healing himself
what's healing him other pigs healing
him
[Music]
are you kidding me I set all this up so
they would heal him
[Music]
that's to get away
[Music]
[Music]
come on
Oh
what their shape right in front of water
sheet Jesus Christ that was a lot more
intense that I intended please tell me I
was recording that that was I will never
want to do that again
oh my god the pigment healed him you
guys healed him oh they're dangerous PB
papa
where's baby Popo then you're safe
we did it spend with didya I'm shaking
dude I'm not kidding so like Oh nervous
all the adrenaline that was crazy dude
what a madness peepee poo-poo peepee
poo-poo you're safe all he made it here
awesome people
I get his freakin oh my God look at all
the golden swords they got all the
golden nuggets
[Music]
all right you got it you gotta go I
don't care frankly don't care
gotta get rid of these flowers how
strong was my armor though
can we talk about that uragan you're
safe you're safe
yo get yes okay so we got a nether star
that's right elaborate that how many
babies and they're adults now - yes
there's something very special you can
do with another star let me double it
you can make a beacon I think yeah you
make a beacon with obsidian then this is
perfect actually because now we need
need we can use swims grave for two
purposes Jurgen Jurgen can help us in
the afterlife spin no no I'm not
desecrating great elaborate that I don't
need judgement from someone called Allah
betta now beacon also needs to see the
sky so we need to go to the very top I
can't believe the meatball made it
without a scratch we talked about the
fact that I spent all look at the
aftermath of all the explosions I have
to go okay so we gotta go get some
obsidian
ah and look at that yes
what in the world not even asking these
blocks represent what a sheet
[Music]
the golden blocks represent my boy
uragan
[Music]
the first
[Music]
and the diamond blocks represent Jurgen
the second
[Music]
they spent IKEA birth there's something
I want you to see
I'm
Jurgen Jurgen one what there she
[Music]
Wow
that it's cool you see this man they
died to give us drink oh my god IKEA
tower through the skies and beyond let's
not forget to pay our respects as well
they died to give us this
[Music]
you